our deepest sympathies and condolences
to the families
they're enduring this tragedy right now
but I cannot agree what the chief said
anymore
this is a fine City a fine County and
absolutely amazing state
and we are not going to allow one
tragedy to Define us
this incident occurred at approximately
10 34 pm
near the 200 block on Broadneck Street
here in Dave on Tallapoosa County all
right
there were four
lives
not fatalities lives
they were four lives tragically lost in
this incident
and there's been a multitude of injuries
as they said this is going to be a long
complicated process
we're thankful to the share to the chief
to everyone to the district attorney
for all of their support we're going to
continue to work through in a very
methodical way
to go through this scene to look at the
facts and ensure that justice has
brought to bear for the families
we will do that and we we can also
confirm that it was tied to a birthday
party we were able to confirm that that
it was tied to a birthday celebration we
can't share anything further at this
time